alors je voudrais d'abord accueillir
tout le monde à Valmer
je suis épaté par le nombre que vous
êtes ça prouve qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens qui aiment les beaux arbres c'est
bien les visiteurs sont venus pour une
remise de diplôme un peu spécial
attribué à deux sophora japonais
pleureur planter il y a près de deux
siècles une époque où tout ce qui
provenait d'Asie était à la mode
originaux et étonnant les deux arbres
cousins de la glycine figurent désormais
sur la liste des arbres remarquables de
France
c'est surtout l'esthétique sont des
arbres tout tordus tout tourmenté qui
fait qui sont quelqu'un qui passe à côté
et forcément attiré par cette le sophora
pleureur n'est n'est pas un arbre très
rare dans les parcs et jardins par
contre la forme qu'il a pris
probablement à la suite d'une mutation
génétique un jour en fait un arbre très
très curieux qui lui donne sa
remarquabilité
remarquable la plupart des arbres du
Château de Valmer le son comme ce chêne
pédonculé commun de nos forêts le plus
ancien du parc ou encore se cèdre du
Liban planté vers 1810 cet arbre est
incroyable parce que malgré son grand
âge il pousse vigoureusement de entre 10
et 20 cm par an c'est tout à fait
étonnant pour ainsi vieillard il
continue à pousser
l'ensemble du Parc de 60 hectares de
Valmer s'est vu remettre un label pour
sa diversité et sa beauté naturelle
son dessin historique du 17e siècle avec
des très belles allées des carrefours
des colonnes dans les carrefours donc le
dessin est historique est très beau
c'est un par composé principalement de
chaîne pédonculés mais aussi avec une
autre une grande variété d'arbres
différents il y a des châtaigniers il y
a des Merisiers il y a des alisiers et
donc ça ça participe à la biodiversité
d'une forêt en fait en centre Val de
Loire une soixantaine de sites et
d'arbres sont actuellement estampillés
pour leur caractère remarquable